[Music]
the british royals have had their pick
of lavish palaces and castles to call
home but now prince william and his
family are leaving their london mansion
for a more rural cottage close to where
the queen has lived since the pandemic
began raymie innocencio is in windsor
this morning with the details on this
modest little countryside home raymie
jamie good morning there that's right
this is a royal relocation and the duke
and duchess of cambridge are retreating
from central london to the relative
quiet here in windsor they're saying
that they just want to give their three
kids the closest start to a normal life
as possible
but being in the most famous royal
family in the world that won't be easy
seen with the queen elizabeth ii for her
platinum jubilee in june the cambridges
were center stage for the iconic
buckingham palace balcony shot beamed
worldwide to steal away from the public
eye the family will be moving to this
cottage adelaide cottage part of the
queen's windsor estate a four-bedroom
home more than 200 years old
they'll be paying market rent and have
no live-in nanny while also living
closer to the monarch roya nica is the
royal editor of the sunday times every
big decision that happens in terms of
the monarchy
william and his father are involved so i
think having that proximity being able
to see the queen much more easily more
frequently you know a few times a week
rather than once a week it's going to be
great for both of them
william and kate will also be closer to
harry and meghan if they should visit
and stay at nearby frogmore cottage
their uk home
will and kate will keep their 20 room
home at kensington palace as their
official residence together with their
10-bedroom manor in norfolk anmer hall
their children george charlotte and
louie will start the new school year
here at the lambrook prep school several
miles away windsor residents are
weighing in i think it's great that
they're coming back to windsor where it
feels like they belong to me so yeah
it's lovely news
and the public is used to seeing the
monarchy grow up from prince william and
harry's first days at school with
princess diana in the late 1980s it's
been a rite of passage
with william's children prince george
and princess charlotte following in the
family footsteps in recent years
this move is about them prince george is
going to be king one day that's an
enormous thing for anyone
his childhood years they want you know
to give him the best possible chance of
having a normal life before he starts to
contemplate that
but of course a royal life will never be
a normal life get this tuition fees for
each of their kids is going to push
nearly 25 000 every single year and the
fact that they now have three homes
under their name when the rest of the
country is facing inflation at 40-year
highs and wondering whether they can
afford power and food has a lot of
people upset tony
yeah that's not normal that's pretty
royal a lot of people are going to be
counting the rooms in their house do i
have 20 do i have 10 40 i'm not sure uh
romeo sensei in windsor fourth remy
thank you very much uh yeah it's all
relative i suppose what modest is i put
normal in quotes yeah i just like
they'll be closer to grandma and kate's
parents live nearby too oh is that right
yeah but david at that on that level it
is 100 normal right it's right people
and family yeah next door to grandma